Donald Trump is accused of 34 felonies
and on paper it is true that
individually each of those felonies
could potentially Garner four years in
prison in some insanely hypothetical
sense we have already seen a number of
legal opinions about this and these 34
felony counts are all related more or
less to the same act or same scheme you
might say and a number of legal experts
and remember none of this is my opinion
I'm just going by what other legal
experts have said while in some
extraordinarily vague sense you could
say Trump is facing 136 years in prison
realistically the maximum he would be
facing for all of these counts would be
four and I believe the real number will
be zero